hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round nine of the 2018
batumi Chess Olympiad it's a game from
the top of boards a poll in this playing
against the United States and on board
one we have a young sister of Duda
versus world chess championship
Challenger Fabiana Caruana now it's a
very interesting I couldn't watch the
entire coverage as I was in Zagreb today
but I did post a tweet about what are
your predictions about to this do the
vs. Caruana metro so as you can see 43
two people voted that cora wanna wins
70% 21% that it will be a draw and only
9% that Duda would actually win this
game so very nice and if you look at
dude as a last couple of opponents for
example he won a very nice game against
vastly one took a brilliancy you might
say then after that he draw a he draw
drew a game against a shocker diamond
tiara and then in the previous game he
drew a game against LaVon Ariane with a
would a brilliant rook sacrifice so
meeting lastly one choke and then facing
2800 player and then almost 2800 player
and now facing the World Chess
Championship challenger definitely not
an easy tournament for young polish
Grandmaster so without further ado let's
see let's see how this game went we have
c-4 by Judah the English opening e5
Knight to c3 and the knight to f6 and
I'm warning you this game is not for the
faint of heart as it's a very intense
9th to f3 Knight to c6 the four Knights
variation of the English we have III and
the Bishop to b4 Queen to c2 but she
captures on c3 Queen captures on c3 and
the now Queen to e7
perhaps with ideas of pushing me for so
d4 immediately
we have nightcap Knight to e4 wooden an
attack on the Queen Queen to d3 and now
he captures on d4 Knight captures on d4
and here corona castles we have Bishop
to e2 and now Queen to b4 with check and
here while it could block check it's
best to play King to f1
is a well-known line that was played
plenty of times by many strong
grandmasters King to f1 and now comes
the Queen back to e7 f3 are kicking away
the night we have night to c5 attacking
the Queen the king will be ready to
perhaps castle artificially which King
to f2 and the rook may come into the
game and this is a position that was
already on the board this year I was
played in the same field Cup between
Wesley so and Sarah Kerrigan here in
this position
what's this so continued with Queen to
d2 and that game was a draw for this
game do the prepared Queen to c3 so this
is a new move and now we have a
completely new game that is not
available in the database and ok d6
karana prepares to develop the
light-square bishop we have knife
cappers and c6 b captures on c6 and now
b3 so what what is definitely ok here he
still has the bishop pair and black's
pawn structure is somewhat weakened but
it's not so that that big of a deal here
b3 was played you could consider a move
like before what ideas of pushing a4 and
going for some rapid pawn pushing on the
Queen side but after Knight a for
attacking the Queen Queen to c2 the
night will come to b6 and now it's it's
not all that clear is if this is
actually good for white
so instead Duda goes for b3 a slower
idea preparing Bishop hurt sorry Bishop
to b2 we have a 5 and the now comes
Bishop to b2 so already you can see that
Duda is threatening checkmate and g7
Fabi stops this would f5 the queen is
now preventing checkmate and also f5 is
nicely covering d4 square preventing
white from any for ideas himself not at
the moment
of course when the king is on f1 but in
the future here you could go King to f2
castle artificially and so on and so on
but first do that this has to go rook to
d1 and okay Bishop to e6 Caruana
also develops his pieces and only now
King to f2 and here as the rook moved
from a1 this lost Caruana
to get rid of his
isolated pawn on da file he pushes a
four before is played and now comes
Knight to d7 Cara wanna play 937
spending only a few seconds on the clock
but also possible is actually a three
but a three is a is a wild engine mood
that perhaps was also looked at at home
by bike or wanna but it's it's a very
nice line that shows how how engines
really you know simplify everything
because now after Bishop captures you
can simply go tonight to a four attack
the Queen after Queen to c2 now you push
c5 and now after B captures on c5 Knight
captures on c5 and here even though
white can play Bishop captures pawn
capture so you do have CC points this
rock is coming to a6 the other rook is
coming to eight and with the doubled
rooks and the a file black has full
compensation for this pawn and why a
white will most likely not be able to
hold his own extra pawn so a very nice
idea but okay after B fortnight's to d7
rook to d2 and now comes f4 rook the c1
if you play something like e for it
seems like the the most appropriate
thing to do then rook to f6 what ideas
of rook to g6 or h6 would be very
annoying for white
so after f4 we have worked the c1 and
now comes a rook a to d8 rook comes to
d4 and now F captures on e3 Queen
captures on d3 and only now c5 b
captures on c5 Knight captures on c5 and
now comes Keith the g1 bringing his King
to safety and getting it away from the F
file Queen to f7 now threatening all
sorts of discoveries with the bishop
putting 2 f2 moving the Queen away and
the now comes Bishop to a5 and okay
Bishop back to F 1 we have rook to e7
and now Bishop to a3 an interesting move
is perhaps Rima nuvaring to this Bishop
tutu more useful square via Bishop to e4
as you can't capture the bishop due to
Queen captures an f2 but after something
like route to d2 the bishop will
we'll riemann over itself to a different
diagonal but kuranes decides against
this so we have rook to e5 and now comes
Queen to d2 doubling on the D file rook
F to e8 now karana doubles rooks on the
e-file and now comes the rook to d5
offering a trade of rooks and now h6 if
you exchange here for example rook
captures then pawn captures will be very
strong as now black will constantly have
to keep an eye on his backwards weak
backward c7 pawn and also the a for pawn
will not be all that impressive
so instead after look 2d v h6 karana
doesn't mind if the exchange happens on
e5 so first the Bishop captures on c5 d
captures on c5 and now we have Queen to
a5 I think the Fabiano that your pawns
on the Queen side are somewhat weak but
Khurana ignores him he simply plays
Queen to e7 and now it is possible to
capture a pawn for example if Queen
captures on a4 you get rope captures on
d5 and after pawn captures Queen to e3
check but you don't want to allow this
Queen to III check it looks very very
annoying King to h1 oh and while you
can't capture on c1 right away because
Queen would capture on e8 you can play
something like Bishop to d3 and now it's
things have gone crazy here you would
really have to figure out what to do
here but if you're really not sure you
know and you have to reach time control
perhaps you don't want to waste too much
time you of course you cannot capture
because now this capturing and c1 will
lead to the checkmate after white gives
up all of his pieces but yeah after rook
to e7 do that decides against this he
plays rook d2 d1 controlling the e1
square and now we have Queen to g5 again
Fabi offers da for porn but Duda against
this again decides against it
first King to h1 not allowing this Queen
to e3 to ever come with check we have
Queen to e3 now and here comes Queen
captures on c7 Queen to f2 and now comes
Queen to a5 you do have to keep an eye
on the
Square and now Queen captures on a to
buy car wanna rock to a one attacking
the Queen Queen to b3 and now comes h3
making some additional squares for the
King if things get crowded on the first
rank King - h7 and the now comes rook to
d5 if you play something like rook
captures then you get pawn captures and
yes black does get a nice past point
here but white also gets a very nice
pass pawn here so not not something you
want to do so after rook to d5 Bishop to
c2 is played and now we have Queen to d2
a very nice move and here you don't
really want to allow something like a
three and then this Bishop to d3 to come
with check if you allow this check then
you get the Bishop captures rook
captures with an attack on the Queen and
after the Queen moves you can simply
capture this pawn rook e8 captures on a3
and you've just lost a very nice pawn so
after Queen to d2 Fabi goes back with
the Bishop Bishop to g6 and here this is
move 40 so time control has been reached
by both players and it's very
interesting undo this next move he he
spends 20 minutes and although it's it's
a move that seems to have cost him the
game it's actually not not at all easy
to find a useful move here for white
hear the engines recommendation as it is
a very wild position is actually King 2h
2 to allow look after son b5 and after
seek after Sundy 583 and now after Queen
to a5 going after after the two pawns
now Queen captures on d5 Queen captures
on a3 and now after c4 Queen to c3 you
have to blockade the passed pawn and
after Bishop to d3 Bishop captures C
captures and now rook to d1 and with the
material being equal on the board a
white will be able to prevent this D
pawn from from moving forward you will
not really be able to improve the
pressure with black because if you try
and get the King over and then you will
simply expose him to too much danger so
while this is a definitely the way to go
for white it's pretty much impossible to
find something like this as do that it's
20 minutes on his next move so here he
played Queen to a5 and Caruana really
punished to this excellently so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find it the move Caruana played I'll
give you a couple of seconds as usual as
but you know you take as as much time as
you need as it's not a very easy move to
find for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent Punisher of not so obvious
inaccuracies and for those who just want
to enjoy the show
now corrode the move karana played was
Queen to b4 and Queen to b4 it's
excellent for many reasons one such
reason is that if you capture the Queen
for example Queen captures you get C
captures now with two points and now I
have to route captures on a four rook
captures here and now after pawn
captures on d5 you get rook to e1 and
there's no way to protect the bishop
because after Kings you want you get
Bishop to d3 and black is winning here
on the other hand after this Queen to b4
move if you just move the Queen let's
say play rook to c7 Queen to c7 then you
get rook to e1 and again a very annoying
move that comes with a similar idea and
now after rook captures rook captures
and King do you want you don't have
Bishop d3 because the rook is guarding
d3 as well but Queen captures on c4 the
bishop is pinned and black wins this so
after Queen to b4 a rook captures on a4
was played by Duda but it leads to a
very similar outcome Queen captures on
a5 route captors on a5 and now looked
after Sun d5
we have pawn captures here and now comes
rope to e1 so a pretty similar idea King
to g1 and now Bishop to d3 there's no
way to prevent losing losing the bishop
but now comes rope captures on c5 rook
captures on f1 with check King to h2 and
now comes rope to d1 and here we have a
very interesting position where Duda has
two points two points for the for the
bishop and you might think that okay
this is now completely reasonable I'm
just gonna resign this you know shake
kuranes hand for playing such a
wonderful game
I made one silly inaccuracy he took
advantage of it it's all over
but not quite a doodle continues this
game he plays came to g3 and okay here
we have Bishop to f1 by Caruana and
improvements to this Bishop to f1 would
have been a move that is not all that
obvious to find but Bishop prefer f1
comes with the idea that rook to d2 will
attack the pawn but even better is
Bishop to a6 forcing this rook to keep
an eye on the d5 pawn and now waiting
for whites to make a move pushing any
pawns wouldn't really be all that
impressive for white and when white
finally decides to make a move with the
king only now you get Bishop to f1 and
now you can't really protect the the
pawns here if you protect it with the
rook then rook captures on d5 if you
pull the pawn then you lose the h3 pawn
and if you go back with the King then
you've just gained a move
rogue d2 would now grab this pawn but
okay it perhaps would be a small
improvement Bishop to f1 Oh immediately
by Caruana
with King to f2 and now comes King to g6
age for Bishop to d3 and here a very
nice tactical shot by Duda h5 would
check a very nice move because now if
you capture with the king you get the d6
a discovered check King to g6 and rook
to d5 threatening d7 and d8 with Queen
here black would have to go up to f1
check and after King to e3 now comes the
bishop to f5 first you have to move the
rook so look capture some d1 will not be
possible but now these seven Bishop
captures rook captures and now orokin
two points each this is a drawn endgame
so after h5 King to F I was played and
now we have rook to c7
now going after the pawns and also
preparing to push his own past D pawn we
have King back to f6 and now comes to
look back to see six with check King g5
and now rook back to c7 corona tries at
g6 and okay H captures on g6 will have
Bishop captures on g6 and now rook to d7
look the d2 check we have King to g3 and
now Bishop back to d3 would ideas of
playing Bishop to f1 rook to e7
we have Bishop back to f5 now attacking
the d5 pawn and now comes King to H do
we have h5 and the now comes d6
again if you capture it immediately real
characters on d6 then G 4 is a very
powerful move after a h captures G
captures Bishop captures or King captors
for that matter doesn't really matter
you would get this rook and Bishop
against a rock and game where black will
white will be able to hold a draw so
after d6h 4 was played and now come to
rook to g7 check King to f4 and now
comes Rock to g8 rope captures on d6
grabbing the pawn but now again do the
finds a very nice idea g3 he's able to
trade off all of the pawns we have King
captures on f3 and now comes pawn
captures on h4 rope the detail with
check and now comes King to g1 and this
appears to be the critical moment in the
game one of the critical moment but no
this is the critical moment of the game
where Khurana actually has a series of
winning moves here but I don't think
this is possible for a human to find but
feel free to pause the video here and
you know give it your best but by giving
your bed don't even pause the video if
you're not planning on spending at least
I don't know 10 minutes on it it's very
very complicated so okay for those of
you who were able to do it you know I
congratulate you as I struggled
realizing how this was even possible
while the engine was explaining me
explaining it to me as it's really
really not all that I meant for those of
you who just wanted to enjoy the show
okay the the engines favorite is rook to
d1 but the this leads to the obvious
move that will come later so we're just
gonna disregard this one and go for the
main one in the game karana played a
Bishop to g4 and he tried a similar idea
but it's actually Bishop to e4 that wins
the game here this comes with a very
very difficult idea
best best just show it for example now
if you look to f/8 check you play King
to III the rook doesn't allow the King
to move the second rank of course you
don't want this and the bishop is very
useful it covers the h1 square so what
you want is that some point for this
King to be on f1 and you want to play
King to a rope to h2 to h1 checkmate for
example so how to accomplish this ok
white will play something rook rook to
f7 first you have to get rid of the h4
pawn for example rogue g2 check now you
can go to h1 12 some discoveries you
have to go to f1 and now comes rook to
h2 and okay now all seams now you
understand why I should have to go to e4
to cover h1 so now you can't go rob the
Kings you want because the rook to H 1
will be checkmate the bishop and King
are covering these two squares so rook
to H 1 will be checkmate
so to avoid checkmate you have to move
the King so the rook can come save you
and now you lose the H pawn so ok this
is how you win the H pawn while still
keeping the king in the in the mating
net now comes Luke to f2 White has to
play something still you have to keep an
eye on the f1 Square Rock h1 check rook
f1 rook to h2 white will simply move
back still has to keep an eye on the f1
Square and now you go look to a -
threatening rook to a1 checkmate and
okay rook to d7 now you have to waste a
move with rook to be - this is a very
important technique now white still has
to keep an eye on d1 you can't allow
rook to be one checkmate
so here rook to b8 and now you play
route back to g2 and this is where the
magic happens now you have to see that
the bishop is also guarding c2 so you
can play a move like king to d1 because
you would get rope to g1 checkmate so
your only options are look to a fate
that covers the f1 square or King to f1
unfortunately for white king - f1
doesn't work because now you get rook to
h2 with the threat of checkmate rook the
g8 trying to prevent checkmate but now
you get
rook to c2 again you're threatening rook
to c1 checkmate and now there's there's
no saving white you can't prevent with
rook to the eight because
rook to see
would simply force you to give up the
rook and win the game on the other hand
the only move that prolongs checkmate is
rook to g1 but now you get rook to see
one check King to h2 look to h1 check
again you see the importance of the
bishop in Gani for King to g3 and now
comes roof to g1 with check King to h4
finally winning the rook white is is not
able to stay on May 2 this and black
will not win the game
so after this rook to G to move we see
that the rook can't stay here
you can't play anything rook to f1
doesn't work so you have to play rook to
f8 to avoid checkmate with rook to f1
and now comes Bishop to g6 again a very
very important move covering the e8
square not allowing any tricks and again
White has black has to decide what to do
here still you can play rook to d1
because the bishop is guarding the C 2
square so rook to G 1 is the threat of
checkmate and rook has to keep an eye on
the F 1 square so what do you do here
rook to f6 and now you go or all the way
here look to be 2 again you can either
check but then Bishop to e4 will be
winning and if you capture the bishop
then of course look the c1 will be
checkmate so you have to play something
else
rook to d6 you have to prevent this rook
to be won by being able to play rook to
d1 now you get Bishop to d3 and now
there's really nothing to do here
anymore you have to play rook the e6
check and now after Bishop 3 4 you have
this position where now everything is is
set and now it doesn't matter what white
plays after rook to these six again
threatening preventing checkmate via
rook to d1 now you get rook to h2 but
now it's a completely different story
again King to d1 doesn't work because of
rook to h1 after rook to f6 blocking
this check now you get rook to e2 check
King to f1 or d1 doesn't really matter
black will just go to the other way now
you get rook to be 2 and now you get the
exact same position that was at the
beginning of this entire maneuvering
only the king is already on f1 so this
is a
it's problem now there's nothing to do
anymore after King to g1 now rook to g2
is coming and after King to f1 now comes
Rock to g5 a very very important move
and now there are no more moves that
save white after King to e1 you get you
will receive rook to g1 first you will
receive Bishop to d3 but then after you
block here and now you will get rook to
H rook to h5 and now there are no no
more options here if instead of this
rook to e6 you try to keep an eye on the
F file and go rook to f8 then Bishop to
d3 check is coming this will also be
very unpleasant after King to e1 then
comes rook to g1 rook f1 and rook
captures so that's not possible so
that's why rook to e6 and now we get
rook to h5 threatening rook to h1 and
now you cannot prevent anything because
the king is already on f1 so nothing to
do here King g1 rook rook h1 so here you
would simply have to capture the bishop
and the now King captures and now a king
and rook will win against the king so
definitely not an easy move to find bush
up to e4 Caruana in the game played
Bishop to g4 but now the win at the
winning any any series of moves is no
longer winning for Caruana
but as his team is losing Hikaru
Nakamura lost on board 3 he has to keep
torturing young young Duda and perhaps
grab something more than a draw here
rook to f8 check King moves and now
comes h5 you have to give up this pawn
as it's pretty much irrelevant we have
bunch of characters on h5 and now a rock
to g8 check bishop moves and now rope to
a rock to f8 keeping an eye on this f1
square not allowing the King to go
anywhere so here we have looked to d6
Khurana will try a lot of things but
nothing works unfortunately for him rook
to f2 rook to d1 check King to f4 rook
to f1 and an oops sorry about that
I mistakenly
took it all the way back so here we here
we were yeah he gave up the pawn Bishop
captures rook g8 we have Bishop to g4
and now rope to a fate covering the F 1
square root 2 D 6 and now rook to F 2
simply controlling the F file rook to d1
the rogue blocks
rook to D to a rook to a fate and now
rook to e2 just trying to waiting for a
blunder from Duda rope to f7 rook to e1
and now rug blocks with rope to f1 look
to eat to would have looked back to a
fate and now Bishop to e6 and okay rook
to f6
we have Bishop to h3 and now comes again
rook to g6 with check forcing the King
back
Bushra blocks and now look back to it f6
simply controlling the f1 square rook to
G to check King moves and now rook to h2
threatening rook to h1 as now the bishop
is also very conveniently covering the
e2 square but now comes King back to g1
a Rakhi - we look back to f8 again
keeping an eye on the f1 Square and now
rook to e5 rook to f2 we have Bishop to
f3 but now again a very nice move that
that saves white it's a roof to g2 with
check
now of course capturing doesn't really
do anything as it still made the the
White King has no more no move
no legal moves so I have to look - G -
Corona goes back in before we have
worked to a - roof do you want check
King moves and now rook to h1
threatening to grab the rock via rope -
H - but rope to a 7 and there's simply
nothing nothing Caruana can do to
improve his position here check from
King f1 Bishop to g4 we have rook to a3
rook to be to rook to g1 a king to g1
Bishop to f3 Rock to a7 and here the
deposition was repeated a couple of more
times
Bishop g4 rope to f7 rugby eight rook to
f2 bush of to f3
again rope - G - second time going for
this idea came to f4 rook goes back
bishop to e4 and now rook to a3 cut
the king of if the king is cut off and
no checkmate is possible rugby to rope
to h3 a rogue G to check King moves
Bishop to f3 now comes Rock to h8 you
have to keep on checking the black King
a rock - a - and now rook to b8 King
Lear tries to cut off the King but now
Rock the g8 check Mishra blocks and now
rook to rook to e8 again the idea is the
same you have to keep control of d1
square not allow checkmate rook to e1
check rook to e1 Rock to a5 rook to e8
rook the d5 Corona really did everything
he could to save his team but it just
wasn't possible
I rocked to e7 rogue d8 rook to e3 with
check Bishop blocks now comes Rock e7
King F for King to F - Rudy - check King
moves t1 roof to h2 and now rook to a7
rook to e2 check King to f1 look to d2
rook to c7 King to g3 rogue g7 with
check King G Bishop g4 rook to e7
rook to have to with check King g1 rug
d2 King to f1 rookie - Brooke captures
any - finally Khurana offers the rook
and the draw and after Bishop captures
the draw was agreed upon although you
know if I was in their shoes I would
probably even capture the bishop just
you know to have a clear board they
played for so long the game lasted for a
hundred in 18 moves and finally the game
ended in a draw so this is something I
wanted to show you before I forget these
are all of duders opponents so as you
can see he had a kind of a rough start
to the tournament losing the game in run
two against the Grandmaster Luis Gallego
from Portugal and the Maxima shrila
Grove from France in round 4 but then
like we said he defeated Vasily one
choke and then drew against Mahmud Arab
didn't true against 11 aaron and with
the wonderful
rook sacrifice and then again draw
against Fabiana Caruana and it's very
interesting if you look at his alive
rating performance up there he's
actually down for rating points with
this performance so you beat a von
Schuch and then you
draw three games in a row against the
Iranian mommy dro and Caruana and you
are down in ratings
that's just how brutal chess is at the
top also these are the performances on
the board as you can see do the Dragons
Caruana vojta check a draw against
Wesley so pure rune as we've said won
again his game against Nakamura this is
the game that allowed the unites apollon
to beat United States and Tom Chuck drew
his game against the same Shanklin and
before I forget here these are the
standings after round nine so in in a
clear first place is Poland with two
more runs to go into Olympiad then we
have United States Armenia China England
France Russia Croatia in eighth Germany
Netherlands Spain Vietnam Israel
Azerbaijan India Czech Republic
Kazakhstan Ukraine Serbia and Norway in
20th place so there you have it and this
is the strongest Polish team since the
1930s in the third chess olympiad that
was ever played in 1930 Poland won the
Olympiad but they were led by Rubinstein
and Tata cover so it took a lot for
Poland to get back to the top but it
seems that with young shift of Duda
leading Poland that you know they seem
to have a very bright future so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
doubt anyone ever actually watched this
game to the end but you know that that
Bishop to b4 move is simply mind-blowing
I don't think I mean perhaps if you
really study it but Caruana did spend a
lot of time on this move so if he didn't
find it I don't know seems like seems
like a very tough decision to make over
the board yeah I would like to thank
Alexandre put on Kenneth shell berg
Danny McCullough David Rossi and Roth
anger for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here think all for watching and
I'll see you soon
hopefully with another interest
game and hope if I'll have the time I'm
planning to continue the Bobby Fischer
series as soon as soon as possible so
thank you all and I'll see you soon